breaking news it's a terrible story from
israel this morning
a massive loss of life and a crush of
bodies at a religious festival
israeli tv reports that 45 people died
overnight
when worship when worshipers trampled
each other
in a sudden stampede dozens of others
were injured
as elizabeth as elizabeth palmer reports
this was
the first large religious gathering
since israel relaxed
strict cobit 19 restrictions
here's where it happened in a narrow
walkway where a huge mass of mostly
orthodox jews were heading for the exit
then in this cell phone video you can
see the makeshift walls start to buckle
police say a few people fell down on a
slippery patch
and panic did the rest
eighteen-year-old shmuel saw it all
people started to get squashed he said
and when the police didn't open up the
passageway the walls
crashed and dozens were trampled to
death
apart from those who died at least 150
people were injured
some critically ill
i can't breathe he said and then
gradually
some of the screaming stopped
the injured were taken by ambulance and
helicopter to hospitals all over israel
while police and security guards worked
to control and reassure the crowds left
on the site they had been looking
forward to a joyous night of bonfires
and dancing
at the annual lag bomber celebration
where tens of thousands gather at the
tomb
of a second century rabbi instead
they found themselves in a nightmare
this morning prime minister benjamin
netanyahu visited the scene of
one of the worst peacetime tragedies in
israel's history
now you may be wondering why so many
people were allowed to gather together
in one place
israel's had a very successful
vaccination and in fact
large gatherings like that one last
night are being allowed to go ahead
tony all right liz palmer for us in
london liz thank you very much